oh not a minute how are you guys already
in there okay we're all done come to
this whole party oh hang on guys
everybody hold on you guys I don't write
anymore
I've already watch this oh that's what
you are that's you
what could I hit the hell would I why
did I just have one I'm in sort of lower
sidewall on my skin is like lagging out
of the hole yeah no I think it's good
you know my internet speeds almost like
it's ringing I'm a winner I am a warrior
yeah Hobie [ __ ] decide after one yeah I
kicked her last night did you get that
oh wow okay well then come on the
concert with her Oh London oh well we're
all pleased oh my god oh my god oh I got
I get guys I get look where I am
goner oh I see
I'm in the hole bitching like we want to
get oh no we don't want to have it
around
Hajin the log the log puts you in the
hole the log fell in the low mark and
out man oh this isn't like go suffering
it doesn't obey real hello whoa whoa
wacky whoa oh wow
wacky you guys are so random Hey oh
we're / yeah you don't
Wow holy shitsnacks
oh we're supposed to go where exactly
I'm assuming straight across wait is the
one to the what I see guys one of my
welcome watch and follow the way of that
archaeologist go up yeah something like
that
a touché douché I'm all waiter I'm a
winner I'm a winner I'm a winner driver
[Laughter]
oh that's not where I wanted to go oh no
I thought I wanted to go in here hey Bob
did you put it the hole
no you put it in a big bulbous holy he
went for the big one when he should have
gone to the more normal size oh but he
could handle way oh wow Wow Bob the shoe
is on the other foot truly this time
hold up oh it's fine the other mouse hey
what whoa that was a good move was wacky
we go in the thing oh wow look at that
look at 177 yeah it was awesome that
converts no Maxie I'm going whoa look at
all there was oh no oh
tree tree log 43 home you know that's
the grass what do I picked up on oh my
wait wait oh no oh oh oh oh boy all
right there we go
I got a sanguine I know you're all
concerned about me and not yourself
don't worry I got this Oh
our Fox a trippy
blue oh yeah
go in the hole hey lark [ __ ] you
goddamnit oh yeah
look who's it last now didn't last so
that's joke's on you suck another dick
oh right away is with us or in water
okay oh why I mean in a way oh they're a
different path
oh oh oh [ __ ] boy I know it Americans I
am it I'm in a corner guys what I'm up
how's it going not good I tell you that
not good copy don't call down on we
can't jump well you can jump that we're
in the water thing you can do it
regardless
uh-huh okay who wants that someone tell
me they're either borrowed as they go
over that thing mom I'm going one and a
half one over here okay oh that was nice
oh I jumped I made it I did it
I'm a genius okay I'm gonna
are you like 300 doc you fools ha ha
yeah oh yeah [ __ ] it shut up over
three I think is but not it's not just a
recipe to jump it you got it you're
gonna do the jump I think you got a jump
in the water here ha ha ha ha nice try
nice guys I'm like we're never letting
all your scores see how that works
ha ha ha ha oh my god I hit the magic
what did I just stop on you just do that
oh where are we going
Oh jerk why you didn't exist on my
screen society even though I could hate
you [ __ ] close oh cool oh no everybody
oh okay I'm on stroke five already cause
of [ __ ]
I got a bogey going great Queen oh oh
how do you like 20 please please oh yeah
oh yeah I go in
oh gosh oh thank you Bob Bob that's you
that was you know that's me I
you totally roasted never roasted good
god I'm dead Bob how are you gonna show
your face at the alumni now hey you know
what leant over here I think this is a
shortcut
oh it is a shortcut Oh way really 19 any
stroke it is a shortcut are you now wait
[Laughter]
Carter cut Bob we're neck and neck
we're neck and neck and balls I'm a neck
Oh Oh check out the stress I have
nowhere why'd I just stop no no I don't
have the stress you guys see what
happened oh oh oh look at this recovery
this recovery mess okay yeah yeah oh
[ __ ] I just did the same thing
there we go no I'm lined up perfectly
eyes witness perfection on a scale which
never cease Wow Hey look at that
oh not though it's gonna you know yes
man I thought you were gone
you're so close mark oh God
god damn you oh why you flaky delicious
no damn you fish deity hey guys watch
this clam
oh wow I hacked out over 200 thank guys
you look a bomb I'm guys guys I am just
be honest
oh yeah
oh I'm incredible I'm outrageously good
Wow Jack that was the worst thing I've
ever seen in my life the whole thing
would work not just a [ __ ] nah man
that was Oh God God terrible yeah yeah I
made it
oh no there's there's ramps and [ __ ] ash
oh no come on
wait I'm engineer man barley puffing his
mouth yeah I did it
there's Dino eggs over there Wade Wade
dynaweb can you stop being Oh God
[Laughter]
[Music]
please mark the judges cup in his hand
yeah yeah yeah man that's me man
that's me now Bob's winning man wave you
had a nice lead there you really [ __ ]
that one up this is consuming [ __ ]
all right full-page bounce me whoa I hit
a drum boy that that's not far enough
how does yeah that that does not happen
oh no oh no I thought the things about
me they don't about you at all
go get your destiny well kingston ii hey
what's up guys I'm here okay I love
dicks today oh I love mo dictionary
where we all get up and we paint a
mystery painting with our dicks and got
a guess what you think it is
huh huh huh huh take that nerds is
anyone in the hole yet no no if I'm not
in the hole no one's in the hole soda
granmarg liar crap damn it
what about anyone ever Oh huh here you
go
guys I'm here they did it no one's gonna
hold till I get in this all come madam
Wow mark you're the first one in thanks
I know you all [ __ ] I'm great I'm
aware of this fact whoa hello no it's a
trap
hey guys I think it's all well yeah hey
buddy good
what us swabue well show can Taylor why
did I bring on you did I hit one of you
[ __ ] oh yeah oh sorry sir oh I see
it squirmed yeah
cooking huh excuse me I gave you a
friendly Duvall you [ __ ] douche what
- Morley uh-oh
hey Mark time oh yeah that happen
oh [ __ ] you hit the wall on my screen
goodbye oh my god
oh my oh wait you're just you know maybe
you should think positive
why do you think I got this boys it
could be possible you guys think about
it though you got it Bob I believe we Sh
that's it ouch it is how you scream as
you finish this happen that's just what
all youtubers yell whatever that
whatever they do yellow locusts believe
I did hey guys yeah hey hey hey old boys
huh hello it's not a crazy it kind of
crap Ohio what's up everyone
hey guys hey guys Bernard whoa whoa hey
hey Vsauce Michael here I help you don't
you I know I try to check who do i watch
oh cool I guess I got to burn 14 maybe
probably for the best
[Music]
oh whoa whoa whoa I'm on a journey old
about the mouse to save your backs
yeah please oh I am in a whole palette
why did I go on a whole Oh God
guys I'm going backwards apparently guys
I don't know what happened where am I
I went in a funnel Oh what I mean a
pointer look no guys I got a loo guy
talking loop guy hey dude mark don't let
it happen to me again guys
oh wait here we go okay oh you got lucky
I don't know where I'm going man I'm
going there why why you know sock
hey so I'm John hello I think it's not
me at all but hello where did you come
from exactly I don't know
so wherever come in Joe came fried well
didn't get the same number of strokes
you guys did know you got stuff of the
riddim okay then hole is right this oh
yeah what a sound is a stroke
yes rule oh [ __ ] oh crap I see what's
going on here oh sweet baby boys hey no
no no no oh hey Mark I did I decided I
needed that yeah oh [ __ ] I did that
thing that Marcus did oh shut up it
wasn't it's not don't call that my thing
that's not my thing
I did that mark thing [ __ ] I pulled a
remark there golf
[ __ ] me no me no okay good great
excellent made it hey boys
gracious hello I found the whole game is
stupid
yeah oh yeah that's fair wild it suck
hey guys yo Joe hit me though how did me
hit you knows you hit me get one people
people think I'm the loud youtuber oh
I'm pretty quiet uh yeah you are why you
why you grouping me in with a loud one
day touching me Maya
that's not good went from the most
extreme the most underwhelming well yeah
that's not good yeah
nope nope nope you're a really
challenging angle oh oh damn it
with a holy [ __ ] Oh get me out of it Oh
what that's a yeah I'm still losing but
now but as badly as I once was it Oh
what the hell please troops me like
nailed it you know I don't even think if
I was going to be the SS I don't think
I'd want my testicles crushed I'm just
gonna throw that out there right then
and um what brought that up on you well
what's brought it up on me well let me
what hey Roz I need a story your brain
no Jack said it some about ball crushing
and I was just like I have to say it I
don't think I want my ball strike I'm
just throwing out that I don't want my
ball crushed okay I really got a fair
thing to say yes I don't think that's
that great brother mark I don't think no
I don't wait I don't think you agree
you're going to give in a protest this
whole concept here so I think I want my
balls crushed you got me
[Laughter]
[ __ ] you why did I wait clap oh wow
[ __ ] me to pieces but you go away oh
stop hitting me
I'm not trying to hit you oh you've
gotta be to put on my kidney that was
stupid that's you right now wait and
people I mean I can make it our pride
that me mystery boob on my kidneys come
on do it
who buys a PDR em I adore you baby
keep fighting Bob I'm rooting for you oh
I hope I'm right on your ass I'm going
right then yeah that's me I'm on your
ass oh why you got it free a little bit
Oh baby really feel sorry for Molly
because you like the other one that's
fair
circle assess very well Jackie OH
hit the boy all right God when no we're
pretty sure I helped mutters come wider
there
why are you exactly I saw the bowl I
went in the ball what does that do
follow me it's out here oh [ __ ] I did
not understand what you were saying when
you were saying down here haha there we
go ah why am I always do push me god
damn at you Hey oh I'm in it right on
the [ __ ] end are you kidding me it's
a flat white thing now time [ __ ] me God
[ __ ] well [ __ ] you're a manager on Jim
Allen
hey what's up group right oh man just
laughs god yeah don't do that I try it
oh no that's not fair that's not a bar
bar and a half are you sure
yup dear don't you don't do it
I am almost out of strokes guys hate to
say marks how's it going I'm almost a
yeah no I mean it oh my god I'm so close
I'm running a strokes right here hey
guys No oh the bowl I'm so close I'll
flip I made it into a bull that was for
a lot on him get in there into the clam
shell go in oh wow I did it I did it I
did it
[ __ ] me in it
why don't you try why do you always get
filling I don't get sucked in I'm left
in the suck deprivation zone it's like
an anti vacuum out here it's [ __ ] I
really came in third in that after all
that Jess you want something are you
saying that but right I will
[Music]